نعم دعينا نرسم المشهد كالتالي طائرات
اسرائيليه مسيره تطلق صواريخ باتجاه سياره
في بلده خربه سلم التي تبعد اكثر من 10
كيلومترات عن الحدود اللبنانيه الجنوبيه
وبالتالي استهداف خربه السلم اولا يعتبر
بانه ليس ضمن الاطار والحيز الجغرافي الذي
كانت تجري فيه العمليات وان كانت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وسعت من استهدافات
خلال الفتره الماضيه هذا اولا ثانيا
الاستهداف كان بشكل مباشر لهذه السياره
التي كان يستقلها وسام طويل وم احد
مرافقيه وبالتالي العمليه توصف هنا بانها
عمليه اغتيال بمعنى ان هذا الرجل لم يكن
اسوه ببقيه شهداء حزب الله الذين سقطوا
طيله المرحله الماضيه يستهدفون اثناء او
بعد تنفيذهم لعمليات عسكريه مباشره ضد
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على طول الخط
الجنوبي للبنان ولكنها
عمليه استه داف مباشر ضمن الخطوط الخلفيه
والبعيده نسبيا عن خط المواجهه الاول الذي
يشهد الاشتباكات المباشره بين حزب الله
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ثالثا وسام
الطويل هو معروف بانه قيادي ميداني وعسكري
بارز في حزب الله في جنوب لبنان وهو ينتمي
الى وحده الرضوان ثالث رابعا هو ابرز
قيادي ميداني يجري استهدافه منذ انطلاق
هذه المواجهات في جنوب لبنان في الثامن من
اكتوبر الماضي عندما بدا حزب الله ينفذ ما
وصفه بعمليات الاسناد ل جبهه غزه والهاء
القوات الاسرائيليه المتواجده على الحدود
وبالتالي عندما نتحدث اليوم عن استهداف
شخصيه كوسام الطويل وان كانت غير معروفه
على المستوى التراتب ضمن القياده السياسيه
لحزب الله ولكنه رجل ميدان رجل عمليات
خاصه يشرف على تنفيذ واداره جزء كبير من
العمليات العسكر ريه التي تجري عند الخط
الحدودي كان هنالك بعض المعطيات الى التي
اشارت الى انه ضمن وحده الرضوان لا يحتل
مرتبه قياديه متقدمه ولكنه يحتل مرتبه
قياديه تسمح له باشراف شبه مباشر على بعض
العمليات العسكريه التي يتم تنفيذها وهنا
لابد من الاشاره بانه على المستوى الذين
استشهدوا من حزب الله خلال هذه المعارك هو
الاعلى من بين هؤلاء على المستوى القيادي
الميداني المباشر وهنا لابد اشاره الى ان
هو في
ال2 من شهر نوفمبر الماضي جرى استهداف
مجموعه من قاده وحده الرضوان في بلده بيت
ياحون حينها استشهد خمسه من قاده من
القاده الميدانيين لحزب الله احدهم نجل
رئيس كتلته النيابيه البرلمانيه محمد رعد
يعتبر بالنسبه لهؤلاء وشم الطويل بانه
اعلى رتبه من هؤلاء وبالتالي اذا ما تم
تقاطع كل هذه المعطيات نشير الى نقطه
رئيسيه بان الاستهداف الاسرائيلي بهذه
الطريقه بعد العمليه التي جرى تنفيذها من
قبل حزب الله باتجاه القاعده العسكريه
قاعده ميرون التي تم اطلاق باتجاهها 2
صاروخا وبعض هذه الصواريخ كانت من
الصواريخ الموجهه الدقيقه وليست من النوع
العشوائي وفق ما افدتني بعض المصادر
الميدانيه التي اشارت بان نوع الصواريخ
التي جرى استخدامها في ذلك الاستهداف كان
من الصواريخ الدقيقه يمكن ربط هذا الرجل
بشكل او باخر ضمن اطار العمليات التي يشرف
عليها بانه وك له بشكل او باخر تقاطع مع
هذه العمليه وبالتالي اليوم الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي المباشر لوسام الطويل بهذه
الطريقه هي رساله واضحه من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لحزب الله على مستوى تصعيد
المواجهه بمعنى ان هذا الاستهداف سيكون له
ما بعده وهنا لابد من وضع كل الاستهدافات
التي حصلت خلال الفتره الماضيه وكيف
يقراها حزب الله لابد من وضعها ضمن اطار
زمني وتسلسل بدا من خلال استه داف واغتيال
رضي موسوي المستشار في حرس الثوري
الايراني في في بغ في دمشق اعقب ذلك
استهداف الشهيد صالح العاروري في قلب
ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه ويلي هذا الامر
الاستهداف اليوم للقيادي الميداني العسكري
في حزب الله بشكل مباشر وبالتالي ضمن هذا
النسق من الاستهدافات المتسارعه وهذا
مستوى